[Musique]
ithurbide maxime gainey ou capucines à
naves va chanter lemieux homeless de
marine akela key mapping eni vous pensez
que c'est maxime guide et bien si c'est
le cas alors on vous enverra un cadeau
je pense que c'est un smartphone
d'accord en temps ordinaire qui vous
plaît ne bouge pas c'est parti on n'en
voit qu'un relais
pour voter sur une route
un battant un record depuis le début
parce que on vient de s'apercevoir d'une
chose c'est un karaoké mails de ses
palais donc j'ai pas du tout l'air en
tête basse que vous pouvez juste fort
dès le tout début
[Musique]
musique14 soit le tiers
non
[Musique]
allez
c'est impensable
c'est terminé malheureusement c'est bien
parce qu'à un moment donné tu vois
[Musique]
b
être là
m
[Musique]
d
là
allez vous asseoir caroline écouter
frédéric hainard du couple est un ouais
ouais ouais
des chiens fait super du verbiage gentil
pas bien on verra
qu'est-ce que tu le pense et on va
demander à d'autres notre copain qu'est
ce qu'il aurait pensé
france soir a donc un conflit né faut
pardonner sur la fin c'est bien
atteindre le deuxième candidat donc vous
mettez une ou deux que vous gardez dans
votre tête marina c'est maxime kenny qui
vient de redire les 80 on a commencé un
petit peu plus tard parce que c'était un
peu compliqué alors à quoi on pense
house à ce que je ne comprends écoutez
moi c'est qu'on la remette au début que
juste marina démarrent les trois
premiers mois par ces pays continuent
alors attends sur l'armée au début avec
un peu de réverbération callas avec de
la réverbère qui vit réverbération
expliqué expliqué mardi d'ascq et parce
qu'il ne sait pas ce que c'est de la
rumeur c'est du coup on dit de l'arrivée
a pas de la réverbération
[Rires]
allez c'est parti deuxième candidat
maxime puis des concerts parisiens
dix assaillants
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
à
vous voulez
non
ep
est ce réellement
[Musique]
ce lego
locaux
tuyaux
à
[Applaudissements]
mais bon
il est clair imposteur ou
[Musique]
tombé dans le piège du débutant au lieu
de se concentrer sur la tonalité sur la
chanson les sites sur un espèce de
numéros à marina une chorégraphie c'est
l'accomplissement danger c'est de me
rassurer parcours et je connais la
chanson je sais pas s'il vous plaît je
suivais le promoteur en même temps vous
et vous avez inventé des mots qui ne
font pas sûr quand thiago motta où il a
fait sa propre chanson bons plans du
bien c'est au mas écarté de cette
séquence parce que je chante mal à
réintégrer les autres
troisième et dernière candidat j'ai
oublié son prénom à mon combat qu'est-ce
que tu en sois tu en as pensé quoi delà
de la prestation de maxime
il est pas mal mais c'est pas possible
tu te moques de moi
nous voilà
alors marine à vous et des capus
pourrait ne vous inquiétez pas
l'habitude et quand elles viennent ici
elle sait où il met les pieds à les
priver un attaché de presse lui dit ne
t'inquiète pas c'est un moment
douloureux mais ça prendra quelques 10
alors attention
on l'y voit ses parts elle commence
[Musique]
m
ok
ouais mais cette heure
hackney
la consommer
[Musique]
maman
thésée
[Musique]
idéal
merci merci beaucoup mais
j'étais obligé de stopper car on
m'annonce que 40 affiche windows 7 est
de coller la santé s'était bien passé
oui c'est sur twitter a gagné on va déjà
alors je sais pas comment on va faire la
moyenne un pôle smartphones mais déjà on
va demander à marina honnêtement
laquelle elle mieux chanter marina
d'ailleurs avant de donner la note 6 et
si vous ne voulez pas pouvez vous nous
expliquer ce qu'il fallait faire marina
et nous fredonner voilà ce que vous
auriez dû entendre ce que vous avez
entendu ou la micro ou vous le faites
avec celui là mais le refrain oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà près d'auray
c'était de longues alors qui vient iliad
s'est passé un truc et jim carrey ce qui
vous a regardé % vous étiez une candidat
[Applaudissements]
s'appelle comment alors vous mettez la
meilleure note à qui marina
caroline corps déjà ça démarre mal pour
françois qui avait choisi notre ami gay
ni maintenant voyons ce que les
internautes ont choisi
ils ont choisi ou maxime si c'est moxxi
hamas à qui tu es sûr que tu gagnes
françois je te rappelle un téléphone
portable t'es ok mais pour l'instant il
ya égalité puisque c'est pas le choix de
notre chanteuse donc on va demander
encore une fois à notre ami de venir
choisir allait bien
s'il décide que se bâtit des smartphones
le gagnant est le gagnant
le gagnant est maxi
[Applaudissements]
sentimentaux
voilà tu as gagné un smartphone ah ben
voilà enfin tu l'a pas encore vu tu
verras quand tu déballera mais bon moi
tu pourra téléphoner merci beaucoup je
t'envoie aussi ciel